have you read the roommates they're good
right good Sophie mm-hmm I left the
heart pills it look just relax
it'll be fine you haven't had an
incident in forever before today's
showing of Blue Iguana please welcome
our surprise guest the film star Ben
Schwartz whoa hey you do a little boy
you okay he's not good with surprises he
has a heart condition never been around
big movie star before is that what
vision he's just a little shocked er one
of his two favorite actors I'm gonna get
your pale skinny boy take care of it
yeah and so what do you like me from is
like the drama stuff for that comedy
stuff but both both
oh what a fan is that one of your
favorite actors who's the other Sam
Rockwell you said Sam Rockwell guys hey
what's wrong with this guy why is his
eyes closed are you sleeping
Sammy Sammy he's not feeling you can't
hear me but over this Sammy he's not
feeling - hey hey hey wake up wake up
time yeah you know what always cheers me
up when I'm a little sleepy t-shirt
why would you shoot him in the face
where else am I gonna shoot him in the
feet come on hey beaver shot a t-shirt
cannibal I'm so stupid
come on mans edit I think he's a goner
bet you 50 bucks he lives you're on
really that quick yeah it is a mega fan
that is a mega fan you're not looking
very good though looking bad
you should crack his chest open we
should crack open this punch in the
middle a doctor a doctor maybe a real
doctor don't you know a real doctor good
thinking you kidding me dude you really
were great in the movie you really think
so I really felt like you invested
yourself I did the character to me was
way more than what you see in the screen
I know Daisy Clooney George Clooney
what's happening hey hey so we got a
heart victimized I know something's
going on with this horror would take a
lot of selfies um uh-huh
okay got it words sequence warts he said
uh maybe you need some cos amigos he's
not really sure what the problem is
because of me baby aspirin some
similarity casa me ghosts anybody baby
ass Vicks VapoRub about a little salt
bath oh did anybody have a full salt
bath for his feet I do yeah is he dead I
think he's a goner
hello yeah that's right pal in your face
really think I was good this movie dude
I thought you really mixed the comedy
and the drama and the action it's like
Meryl Streep Tom Cruise Jason Statham
that's Bobby Lewis that's what's going
like Don Knotts Oh incredible
anybody have a 1/3 used condom just just
the bottom just just the bottom third
[Music]
you